salut aujourd'hui nous allons voir 19,9
actes sur le cerveau pourquoi 19 parce
que nous sommes en 2019 des choses que
vous ne savez pas forcément ou alors
aussi des découvertes récentes
si vous ne saviez pas tous les jours sur
mon instagram je publie en ce torride et
fun fact de et rigolote intéressante sur
plein de sujets aussi des jeux plein de
choses comme ça
le lien est dans la description toi même
tu sais et maintenant le point tournée
de spectacles de fabien olicard vous
pouvez passer cette séquence avec ce
time conne mais après faut pas le
demander quand est-ce que je passe chez
vous parce que je dis ça fait trente
villes depuis le mois de septembre
il jouera ce soir à marseille le 26
janvier à bilke le 27 janvier à
coudekerque branche le 2 février à
florange le 10 février à bordeaux le 22
février immobile de 26 à saint-etienne
il y à une vingtaine de villes en plus
en francs suisses le 19 juin belgique le
9 mai cliquez sur le lien dans la
description est réservé avant que ce
soit complet le cerveau d'einstein a été
découpée en 240 tranche 240 tranche pour
pouvoir l'examiner un peu plus près mon
pauvre albert
ils sont fous ces médecins et le
résultat passionnant c'est qu'on n'a
rien trouvé de spécial en plus ça on a
fait ça pour pas grand chose mais c'est
rien comparé à la 10eme fun fact que
vous verrez tout à l'heure prenez un
grain de sable
prenez également un morceau de tissu
cérébral exactement la même taille
observez le grain de sable morceau de
tissu cérébral au microscope et vous
allez trouver deux dans plus de cent
mille neurones et plus d'un milliards de
synapses 1 milliards de synapses à la
c'est qui le patron basse et le cerveau
mon gars saviez vous que les bébés font
immédiatement la différence entre leur
langue natale propre langue et une autre
langue et comme les bébés sont super
forts et savent aussi différencier
sportive de langue les mots rail comme
le japonais les syllabique comme le
français et les accentue l comme
l'anglais début 2019 on a fait de
grandes avancées sur la dépendance et la
diction incontrôlée qui n'est pas tout à
fait la même chose par exemple j'adore
les curly je peux m'en passer
alors que la mayo abel
après des tests sur des souris accros
qui recevait une légère punition je vous
gage pâques en disant ça j'ai l'image de
mickey mouse est en train de se faire
fouetter par google donc lors des tests
des souris accroc recevez une punition
légère quand elle est allée chercher
leur récompense est bien 40% d'entre
elles se sont auto ce vrai à cause de la
punition en faisant sa cahute pas cool
du tout pour les souris on a pu
déterminer la zone du cerveau qui gérait
la dépendance et en réduisant
directement l'activité de cette zone les
chercheurs ont pu tout simplement ce
vrai les souris solutions écologiques en
termes d'énergie pure rationaliser en
watts le cerveau consomme 38 watts par
heure
bon après on va pas se mentir on connaît
tous au moins une personne qui
fonctionne à économie d'énergie
waouh je pourrais pas de toi le cul
ouais j'ai une proposition chauloux à
vous faire chatouiller vous maintenant à
l'endroit où vous êtes le plus sensible
évidemment ça vous fera rien le cervelet
a entre autres une fonction qui prédit
nos sensations tout en étant responsable
de nos mouvements
du coup ils anticipent et bloquent nos
réactions attention un sort dégueulasse
à chaque fois que vous vous regardez
dans le miroir vous voyez deux morceaux
deux cerveaux qui pendent oublié vous
pouvez également les toucher donc ça
veut dire que vous pouvez toucher
littéralement votre cerveau ce sont les
yeux les globes oculaires sont des
extensions physique directe du cerveau
vous les verrez plus pareil ça c'est sûr
hein et puis imaginez quand vous dites à
quelqu'un qu'elle a des beaux yeux
maintenant vous pouvez dire tu as de
belles extension de bout de cerveau
juste la halle à peu près ici j'adore
parlons maintenant de l'intelligence
artificielle pour beaucoup c'est la
direction vers le futur en tant que
grand public quand je discute avec alexa
ou gueule ou syrie je me dis qu'il ya
encore du chemin à faire mais il n'ya
pas gratuit en 2015 ce sont 8 milliards
de dollars qui ont été dépensés dans la
recherche générale sur l'intelligence
artificielle et l'année prochaine
en 2020 on devrait
pierre 37 milliards de dollars dépensés
dans l'île et quant au fait de
reproduire à l'identique
informatiquement le cerveau humain je
vous en parlerai dans la fin de chaque
numéro 13 est ce que vous connaissez
votre voix la voix la voix de la rue je
veux dire est ce que vous la connaissez
vraiment en réalité non puisque vous
n'entendez jamais vraiment votre foi
puisque vous entendez en même temps
votre voie externe et votre voie interne
et comme vos os accentue les grades à
chaque fois que vous écoutez votre voix
sur un enregistrement vous avez
l'impression d'avoir la voix un petit
peu plus aigus pour entendre votre vraie
voix il suffit de parler en se bouchant
une oreille comme ça c'est pour ça que
vous voyez souvent des chanteurs faire
ça loïc le cerveau ne contient aucun dr
donc il ne peut pas ressentir de douleur
einstein aurait presque pu se faire
découper les 240 tranche de son vivant
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'ils auraient
survécu à ça c'est quand même pratique
parce qu'on peut opérer le cerveau des
malades tout en les gardant consciente
et en leur posant des questions pour
savoir si tout va bien on leur découpe
vraiment le crâne comme ça ils ardent
une rose et puis après on entre et
fouillé qui on papote avec eux voilà bah
je vais vous laisser imaginer tout ça y
est la quinzième fun fact je vous dirai
comment on va faire bientôt disparaître
la douleur si on veut il paraît que les
femmes ont plus de mal à laisser de côté
leurs petits tracas leurs petits soucis
quotidiens
bon ben ça c'est pas une idée reçue
c'est vrai mais aujourd'hui on sait
pourquoi scientifiquement le cerveau
féminin a une capacité plus faible à se
reposer cette différence notable le
trouve son explication dans plein
d'hypothèses sur l'évolution c'est peut
être aussi parce que c'est elle qui
s'occupait le plus des enfants elles
devaient rester alerte en toutes
circonstances en cas de danger mais ça
c'est qu'une seule des hypothèses parmi
toutes les hypothèses la preuve je bouge
énormément mes bras c'est à dire qu'il
ya beaucoup d'hypothèses
du coup les femmes sont beaucoup plus
amer que nous ont plus de charge mentale
pendant que nous avec une bière ou un
jeu vidéo on peut tout oublier les
chauves-souris utilise
l'écholocalisation pour se déplacer ils
ont une sorte de sonar
mais saviez vous que les êtres humains
sont également capables de le faire
alors forcément il faut beaucoup
d'entraînement et si vous comptiez être
discret pour vous déplacer comme ça dans
le noir le fait de gueuler dans tous les
sens pour vous déplacer ça risque quand
même de vous faire repérer un peu je
vous en parlais tout à l'heure un
cerveau humain simulé sur un ordinateur
c'est comme de la science fiction mais
c'est franchement bien entamée ça
s'appelle le human brain project en 2000
23 il devrait exister un modèle
informatisée du cerveau alors son but
c'est pas du tout de penser à notre
place et nous remplacer ce même pas
possible son but c'est de comprendre
justement ensuite comment fonctionne
notre cerveau qu il y eut libye du livre
de très récentes études en neurosciences
viennent de prouver que notre cerveau
pouvait changer suivant le métier qu'on
fait plus on pratique son métier plus
l'expérience change les aires cérébrales
et modifie en profondeur le réseau
neuronal les imagerie cérébrale qui ont
été faites du cerveau ont même montré
qu'il ya des sortes de déformation
professionnelle du coup j'aimerais bien
voir ça sur youtube heures pour voir
qu'est ce qui est modifié dans son
cerveau ouais mais pour cela il faudrait
qu'il ait un qui l'est un quoi eh ben un
médecin qui puisse le faire pour lui oui
c'est comme ça on verrai ce qu'il ya
dans son cerveau voilà mais puisque le
cerveau change par l'expérience on peut
alors se poser la question suivante la
personne que l'on est ou que l'on croît
être change-t-elle avec le temps vous
avez quatre heures reprenons sur la
douleur ce truc terrible qui paraît
incontrôlable de récentes études
viennent de trouver son fonctionnement
dans le cerveau seulement 30 noeuds
rhône forment une sorte de qg de la
douleur 30 neurones c'est rien imaginer
on à 68 à 100 milliards de neurones
il y en a que 30 qui gère la douleur et
c'est en france qu'on a découvert ça et
ça c'est la classe
c'est surtout très intéressant pour la
science du traitement des douleurs
chroniques où se trouve réellement la
conscience notre capacité à réfléchir
consciemment se parlant intérieurement
de l'intérieur où se trouve la petite
voix elle est cachée dans la caméra a
pas deux fois celle qui réfléchit sans
en être certains à 100% il est fort
probable que la conscience soient logées
dans trois zones différentes du cerveau
lune qui serait située dans le tronc
cérébral et qui serait relié aux deux
autres qui sont situés dans le cortex
ces recherches ont été faites sur des
personnes qui était dans le coma ou dans
un état végétatif et grâce à ça on a pu
trouver de nouveaux traitements pour ces
patients mesdames et messieurs oui je
vous l'annonçais le monde en sera
bouleversée
le cerveau continue de fonctionner après
la mort
le centre médical universitaire de stony
brook à new york a démontré que le
cerveau fonctionne et encore après le
décès pendant 60 secondes 60 secondes où
la personne a conscience qu'elle les
morts après avoir analysé des cas très
différents d'arrêt cardiaque ayant
provoqué un décès et où l'on a pu
ramasser personnes à la vie évidemment
les ressusciter ont pu répéter des
conversations qu'avait le personnel
hospitalier entre eux pendant qu'ils
étaient morts revenons sur
l'intelligence artificielle
saviez-vous qu amazon avait développé un
programme d'intelligence artificielle
qui s'appelle reconnaissions en bon
français ce soft analyse les photos il
est capable de dire quels objets sont
sur la photo quels animaux sont sur la
photo les races des différents chiens
présents sur la photo est encore plus
flippant les émotions que ressentent les
personnes qui sont sur les photos et en
plus le programme est capable de donner
une note de fiabilité de ses propres
analyses sur une note de 1 à 100 je vous
mets un lien dans la description
j'ai bien sûr gardé une dernière info
qui m'a rendu dingue
et là je vais vous la donner sur mon
instagram je plaisante je vais la donner
maintenant la société tech et verts a
lancé le projet brain fly ils ont réussi
à faire voler un drone je sais pas si
vous allez vous rendre compte à quel
point c'est fou qui était contrôlé
uniquement par la sensée décollage vol
atterrissage trouve ça vraiment hyper
flippant qu'on puisse contrôler des
choses comme ça par la pensée mais c'est
très encourageant par contre pour des
personnes qui sont handicapés ce genre
de technologie de contrôle par la pensée
peut vraiment aider ces personnes là
mais après c'est ça dépend comment on
s'en sert et comme disait le sage un
grand pouvoir implique de grandes
responsabilités
vous en voulez plus alors n'oubliez pas
que tous les jours je publie en story 1
stades et fans patte sur plein de sujets
différents d'ailleurs dit moi dans les
commentaires si vous les suivez comme
d'habitude laïque et si ça vous a plu
si vous n'êtes pas encore abonné
bienvenue et cliquez ici je vous laisse
maintenant avec cette vidéo là qui
devrait vous plaire parce que c'est
youtube qui détermine laquelle va vous
plaire et ici je vous mets la dernière
vidéo qui est paru sur la chaîne à très
bientôt
ciao